thank you mr speaker
with with permission i will make a
statement
i'm grateful to sue gray for her reports
today and i want to thank her for the
work that she's done
i also thank the metropolitan police for
completing their investigation
and i want to begin today by renewing my
apology to the house to the whole
country for
the short lunch time gathering on the
19th of june 2020 in the cabinet room
during which i stood at my place at the
cabinet table in which i received a fix
penalty notice and i also want to say mr
speaker above all that i take full
responsibility for everything that took
place on my watch
sue gray's report has emphasized that it
is up to the political leadership in
number 10 to take ultimate
responsibility and of course i do mr
speaker i'm trying to set out the
context not to uh not to to mitigate or
to absorb myself in any way
the exemption under which they were
present in downing street uh includes
those circumstances where officials and
advisors were leaving the government and
it was
appropriate
to
recognize them to thank them for the
work that they have done and it's clear
from what uh sue gray has had to say
that some of these gatherings
then went on
far longer than was necessary
and they were clearly
in breach of the rules and they fell
foul of the rules
i have to tell the house because the
house will need to know this and again
this is not to mitigate or to extenuate
i had no knowledge of those subsequent
proceedings because i simply wasn't
there
and i have been as surprised and
disappointed
as anyone else in this house
as the revelations have unfolded
and frankly mr speaker i have been
appalled
by some of the behavior
particularly in the treatment of the
security and the cleaning staff i'm
happy to set on the record now
that when i said i came to this house
and said in all sincerity that the rules
and guidance have been followed
at all times it was what i believed to
be true
it was certainly the case
when i was present at gatherings to wish
staff farewell
and the house will note that my
attendance at these moments brief as it
was
has not been found to be outside the
rules the entire senior management has
changed
there is a new
there is a new
there is a new chief of staff
an elected member of this house who also
commands the status of a cabinet
minister
there is a new director of
communications a new principal private
secretary
and another of other key appointments
in
my office
i am confident with the changes and new
structures
that are now in place
that we are humbled
by the experience
[Applause]
and we have learned our lesson and i
want to conclude
by saying that
i mr speaker i i'm humbled and i have
learned a lesson